hello how reject nation it's Greg Alva
here Aloha as well I'm John
we're gonna watch today a patron video
request one of the reward tiers you know
how it goes the chilling Exorcism of
Anneliese Mitchell Myka Misha Misha
Michele either way this is a very
horrific story I've read this I read
about this no idea who this is from
BuzzFeed blue BuzzFeed unsolved
requested from none other than not to
lead Doron I like these guys so we're
going to discuss a case of demonic
possession so chilling a controversial
that it actually became the movie The
Exorcism of Emily Rose it's one of the
view like actual cases of demonic
possession they went to court it's a way
that they like sue the demon was raised
as a strict Catholic and was described
as very bright and Michael
in September 1968 when Annalise was 16
years old she experienced her first
episode of losing consciousness and
later that night she felt as if
something was pressing down in her chest
her took her bed
11 months later in August 1969 a similar
event occurred and her mother took
Annalise to the family doctor doctor
boat and a neurologist dr. loopy who
examined her and even ran an EEG a brain
scan but found nothing wrong
they had pathi sized that it could
possibly be a form of seizure over the
next three years Annalise would have two
more similar episodes it was prescribed
two medications an anticonvulsant
medication and an anti-seizure
medication called Atlantan on both
occasions an EEG would come back normal
with some minor irregular patterns but
nothing that would definitively explain
her symptoms
wellyou're was this it was in spring at
least began to hear knocking sounds in
her bedroom
sounds her sisters would hear as well
but even more alarming and Elise also
reported hearing a voice damning her to
help further rattle when she witnessed
Annalise seriously staring at a statue
of the Virgin Mary with quote eyes
turned black
and her hands seem to turn into big
poopy at least describe horrific visions
of human faces that were tormenting her
and stated that she felt the devil was
inside her she reported smelling
something that had the aroma of burnt
feces a stench that many around her
would report smelling at later times why
do all these people know what burn
around this describe these strange
occurrences to dr. loopy who according
to mrs. Michelle advised them to consult
a Jesuit a claim that colleges priests
and eventually found a priest named
father halt in November 1973 altar
easement with a Korean psychiatrist who
diagnosed her as a neurotic with
possible epilepsy and another
neurologist found she had quote
epileptic patterns and took her off the
lanten and put her on tegretol a much
stronger drug
in July in 1975 Annelise is extremely
odd behavior worsened she barely slept
and prayed fervently all night
she ate spiders and flies and even
living own urine up from the floor she
destroyed rosaries crucifixes and holy
pictures in the walls
Anneliese also exhibited strength that
was quote close to superhuman the rank
her sister quote as if she were a rag
doll and incredibly was observed
effortlessly squeezing an apple with one
hand until quote Brightman's exploded
Wow a priest named father rota with a
man considered an expert on exorcisms by
his peers reported that he was convinced
that Anneliese was possessed and after
deliberations with the bishop an
exorcism one analyst was formally
approved it was to be carried out by a
priest named father Reds on September
24th 1975 the first exorcism Rite was
performed father rent allowed some of
the exorcism sessions to be recorded and
42
I'm gonna play some clips from those
recordings but fair warning these
recordings are perhaps the most
disturbing pieces of audio I've ever
heard sounds like a girl doing a funny
voice they do this your unrelenting
skepticism is exhausting it drains me of
all happiness and energy
[Music]
[Music]
okay placement they provided accurate
details of who was a priest in the 1500s
that was kicked out of the church for
bad behavior these details bad behavior
Anneliese would have no equation that is
the only thing that is strange to me all
the other stuff is just things that a
person could do to learn more about
demonic possession we sat down with
father Gary Thomas a Vatican approved
Exorcist who explained to us different
signs of possession all of these enemies
had one would be an aversion to the
cigarette so a person walks in this
church and can't look at a crucifix and
there they only see the waves of their
eyes
another would be knowledge of hidden
things where the demon will begin to
tell you things about yourself in it but
the person themself one had one way
there would be possessing a kind of
inordinate physical strength in that
moment possess the last last sign is
sort of epileptic seizures to the point
where her family had to tire up to
prevent her from hurting herself it
sounds like most Exorcist and least what
it used to eat he described it as quote
not being permitted to eat despite being
quite frail likely weighing under 80
pounds she exhibited great strength when
people tried to restrain her yeah I just
go bad for her at this point yeah I do
go back definitely torquing also refused
a doctor visit even though she had a
very high fever on June 30th Annalise
had another exorcism only saying please
absolution the next morning her family
went to her room and found her dead
despite seeking medical attention early
on Emily's refused to submit to medical
attention to the end as she and her
family ultimately placed all faith of
recovery into the exorcisms she died of
starvation at the age of 23 after 67
exorcisms only 68 pounds at the time of
her death do you think that just made
her like buy into it more if people
started to exercising me on the reg
demons I would agree with that in the
mine but annalisa believed that she was
possessed she dates
although the exorcisms or the priests or
any of that stuff after her death and
Elise's parents in the two priests were
accused of negligent homicide and the
case went to trial in nineteen
damn olives are the two sides of that
case first let's review the position of
the defense the defense presented
eyewitness testimony and formally
submitted the recordings as evidence of
possession an idea that the court never
seemed to take juice from a non
religious standpoint the defense argued
analyse was permitted to deny medical
treatment as was her lawful right for
what it's worth
medical treatment might have included
tranquilize a horse feeding her and
electroshock therapy quote all
presumably against her will and family
friends via high-carbon her testimony
that in 1976 a few months before Anna
Lisa's death and at least reportedly
quote begged on her knees for hime to
not suggest medical attention to anybody
also worth noting is the fact that
father alt actually looked for medical
help towards the end and on May 30th his
friend dr. Richard Roth visited Annalise
out of what he claims was scientific
curiosity and not as a physician in his
visit dr. Roth claims Annalise had no
external injuries although father
rennes-le-château in cheek and black
eyes an interesting contradiction to say
the last dr. Roth also denied saying
quote there are no injections against
the devil end quote
all the supposed epileptic attacks an
autopsy revealed Anneliese had a healthy
brain with no day
that could have caused epileptic
seizures whoa not even on a microscopic
level end quote
what say you to that I mean no look I'm
not a scientist sorry it's been a long
day I'm not a neurologist I don't know
funny that you said that because the
neurologist said the exact same thing go
instead I'm not a neurologist probably
sounds like more curious with the port's
seeming non consideration of facts such
as serve pupils being unusually dilated
and the absence of ulcers on her body
which are frequently found in victims of
starvation okay any quotes in that I
mean prosecution the prosecution argued
that Anneliese had epilepsy in psychosis
and that the parents and two priests
were liable for failing to act to save
her life
the defense tore down notions of
possession they questioned the
credibility of mother all but the
conclusion from two experts then father
all exhibited signs of schizophrenia
whoa that's weird
he was regarded as doing the exorcisms
but he was the guy that initially held
dental yeah beginning the prosecution
also argued that the medications given
successfully suppressed the epilepsy
like seizures and argued that that
suppression worked into quote a
delusional psychosis associated with
epilepsy
unquote they argue that Annaliza
psychosis was exacerbated by the
exorcism which only played into her
fantasy to piggyback a man and these
often with your faces between exorcisms
where she behaved normal even though she
would behave as a possessed person
during exorcisms it's unclear if the
epilepsy live seizures were stopped by
medication or if they actually stopped
in their home but annalisa psychotic
visions predate the elective medical
suppression basically saying that the
psychosis was brought on by the
suppression of the dress
yeah but it's like we have three dates
three drugs
exactly in the end the court ruled in
favor of the prosecution sentencing
court all defendants to six months in
prison with suspension for three years
and payment from all court costs Sam the
court ruled that Annalise was unable to
make decisions for herself and should
have been forced to submit to medical
care
professor felicitous Dean goodman and
author of a book on the case noted
theories that Annalise was epileptic
were presented as quote a statement of
indisputable fact not conjecture as in
fact they had been in quote how do you
tell the difference between possession
and mental health sometimes both are
going along side by side you have to
determine what is the root cause of the
suffering of this individual we start
out with a discernment and the
discernment involves myself and a whole
team of people I have a medical doctor
clinical psychologist and a psychiatrist
in fact a formal exorcism only happens
as the last resort given the evidence
that we've seen and all the strange
occurrences and the voices I think
there's sufficient evidence to not
conclusively rule out that she was
possessed beyond a reasonable doubt
thank God diagnosed there's a lot of
factors in this case I personally think
there's something going on with mental
health and I'm also think that 67
exorcisms probably don't don't believe
your mind in a good spot that being said
she should have gone to the hospital get
that girl to a hospital she's possessed
or not [ __ ] force her to go to
hospital and let the doctor feel wholly
[ __ ] the shit's floating around TSA kids
spiders don't take him to an exorcist
take him to an F but dude at the
hospital regardless many of the beta
would actually led to Anna Lisa's death
was it a case of mental illness possibly
epilepsy or was this a legitimate case
of demonic possession whatever the real
reason may be the case of Anneliese
Michel
is a tragedy will always remain unsolved
Wow
I don't know what's making me happier
the fact that you can't get it the
struggle in your face as you see your
[Music]
well John what do you think it's time to
squeeze an apple and see which of us is
I guess I would have to ultimately
because there's everything is so kind of
nebulous and it's hard to say there are
like I said they're a bunch of factors I
feel like there's probably some kind of
hyper so specific that there's no
precedent for it mental thing going on
but at the same time you know the
mystery of it all does scratch in my
mind I don't really have a conclusion
for this I feel like it could be
whatever the prosecution rested on or to
win if that's all true that's all true
but then there's other things that I
didn't really talk about what about the
superhuman stirring stuff if she really
had this superhuman strength does that
come from these forms of epilepsy or
seizures or whatever there's certain
things I'm like well why didn't they
touch on this in the core trial does
that mean that the parents and the
priests were just lying about these
incidences I saw the movie I don't
really remember it I remember liking it
I remember what didn't even I don't
remember like spanning so many years of
this woman's life I that's what shocked
me was this went on for like a decade or
something like that about the trial yeah
it cuts back and forth between times so
I guess that's why I didn't really
register that but yeah but this is like
you realize just how much time and agony
was involved in this cuz like 67
exorcisms regardless they should have
taken her to the hospital even if it was
a possession like if the hospital can't
fix it and it would have been yeah this
girl's really possessed yeah I mean I
feel like it certainly checks off all
those boxes of like we might as well try
an exorcism yeah because there's so much
unexplainable and the prosecution's case
at least of this videos to be believed
it seems like they won based off of
facts that weren't entirely accurate cuz
like some of this started before she was
on medication because that was a
compelling exactly exactly
I'm like what about all that stuff from
before then though things like knowledge
you would never have that that you're
spouting off those things make me wonder
if it could be something so yon the
natural realm that's what I wish they we
got some word on the whole I'm sure this
trial would offer ever that's something
I wish we got some facts on in terms of
what the prosecution had to say about
those specific incidences I don't know a
it sounds I I think it was real yeah I
mean I guess my faculties want to tell
me that there has to be some kind of
logical something or other at the end of
this but there's so much mystery around
it and I can't disavow that yeah I feel
like it mean there's parts of America
that are very religious and I'm sure
there are parts of California or they're
religious - especially back then though
America in general was much more of a
religious country yeah so I'd imagine
all that information of religion and
like spouting off names like Judas and
Cain because funny what he was saying
was this like every guy's yeah I find it
very hard to believe that it was just
that that it was only that because they
blamed a lot of it on the medication
above all and stuff before the meds so I
wouldn't be surprised
it's definitely beyond the natural in
some regard I just don't know what
regard it's fascinating though this this
whole subject matter is fascinating
especially now especially now that we
have so many less reasons to be enamored
with the mysteries of life there's
there's explanation information
everywhere you know I think it happened
is Amanda Waller could have recruited
her to be a part of that suicide
government mission gift basket for flies
and spiders keep you stop work for me
that's not for so many years I say yes
it was real because that makes my life
more exciting yeah right I say maybe I
know is easy you guys are funny together
I like these skeptic verses the believer
the forever debate that we'll have in
this country yeah and the world yeah
well thanks Natalie door any smile is a
spooky ass videos nice to get the true
story behind the Exorcism of Emily Rose
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification
Bell to get notified every time one of
our videos is up and check out our
patreon it's a lot of fun over there